The United Kingdom did not vote on austerity policies, it didn’t vote on the insufficient protection
of external borders. The United Kingdom is not a member of the Eurozone, so the euro policies
don’t apply to the United Kingdom. The United Kingdom is not part of the Schengen area
so the United Kingdom is master of its own borders.
So, let’s not invent anything. Stop telling stories, Mr. Farage. You told us,
a few days ago, that you made a mistake on the budgetary aspects of what was at stake
in the relationship between the EU and the UK. If you had said that before the vote, I could have congratulated you.
But you lied. You did not tell the truth. You fabricated the reality.
I enjoyed debating with you, Mr. Farage. We have the same sense of humour.
You have it. I have it. I find it regrettable that this is the last occasion
we will be able to debate because you won’t be coming back.